this week the Trump administration
lifted a ban on the importation of some
trophies from animals hunted for sport
that includes elephant parts despite
statements from the president in
November that such a practice is quote a
horror show the US Fish and Wildlife
Service says it will make determinations
on whether to allow trophy imports on a
case-by-case basis you're going to tell
us more about the new policy and what it
means is dr. M sanjayan CEO of
Conservation International he is also
the executive producer of the new
virtual reality film my Africa which
debuts at the Tribeca Film Festival next
month
sangeun good morning good morning what
does this mean case by case basis what
are the implications for the effort
elephant population we actually don't
know and that's the problem with this
right it's more uncertainty just when we
felt like we were making some real
progress with ending the poaching of
large-scale poaching of elephants in
Africa just when China in January
announced that it's banning its domestic
market for ivory this new factor comes
in and creates uncertainty around how we
manage elephant populations let's let's
talk about the risk to elephants because
they're in grave danger correct
absolutely yes how significant well so
when I was a child when I was in high
school they were probably about a
million 1.2 million elephants in Africa
today there may be about 300,000 the
great global elephant survey comes up
with it's hard to know exactly so the
population has declined it's declined
across the range you know some countries
are doing well and we're seeing the tide
turn the price of ivory is dramatically
dropped from you know two thousand
dollars a kilo you know four years ago
to about four hundred dollars a kilo
today well but just when this is
happening just when we have moral
leadership on this issue when the United
States from the UK when now China can
take some leadership on this issue
this new uncertainty has created a level
of anxiety amongst people who really
care about elephants the president
called this kind of hunting a horror
show and he was probably right and he
has been sort of unstinting at least
publicly in his criticism of it yet this
is happening we're back at this issue
who's driving this I don't know I mean
look I was shocked by this
as you were because President Trump was
crystal clear on this in November not
just tweeting but publicly made
statements after story you did a New
York Times didn't others you know what
was unusual about this new announcement
that there's some backtracking of this
is case by case allowing of trophy
hunting for elephants to be brought back
into this country that announcement was
made by Safari Club International which
in itself is a little unusual we expect
impartiality amongst our agencies like
US Fish and Wildlife Service that they
should be determined by science so
having a organization private
organization announced this is a bit
unnerving just for people who don't know
what is safari club and it's it's
basically an organization that supports
trophy hunting of sort of in primarily
big game species around the world and
they were making the announcement on
this that's how we learned about it do
we have any information on what the
guidelines actually are gonna be for
these judgments and and who's gonna be
essentially judging it no we don't have
any clear understanding of what these
guidelines are gonna be or how you're
gonna judge it now understand that
hunting has been used as a conservation
tool frankly I'm a hunter myself right
and in this country hunting is used as a
very strong conservation tool but even
in the United States we don't hunt
endangered species if we don't hunt
endangered species here why do we think
it's okay to hunt endangered species in
Zambia or Zimbabwe when clearly the
regulations are far more obscure what
needs to be done to ensure the survival
of elephants what can ordinary Americans
people watching the show do how can
people participate in ensuring their
survival well don't buy anything that
has ivory on it that's simple and it's
illegal now and it should be that way
and and then get your voice heard you
know make your voice heard we want the
US Fish and Wildlife Service to have an
open process where public can comment on
this a transparent process President
Trump has the opportunity right now to
bring leaders around the table and
continue to have the leadership of the
United States has had on this issue and
really deal with the big problem of
elephants we just habitat loss and
large-scale commercial poaching I mean
this hunting issue is frankly a sideshow
and it's distracting attention away from
what is
really needed very quickly we mentioned
your virtual reality film my Africa tell
us what it's about
oh it's an amazing story spoken from the
from the perspective of symbaloo
communities from a from a young woman's
perspective of living with wildlife in
northern Kenya it's spectacular
everything from wildebeest crossing the
Maasai Mara to baby elephants and its
opening at Tribeca
and the wonderful Lupita the star of
Lupita is has lent her voice to it and
he does great job dr. engine thank you
so much for being with us this morning
thank you